Hey, what you somebody told me to come
to
I know you asked me why. You asked me
why. I'm here like just, you know, just
trying to engage with you guys. You guys
set up the tent. We're not here to
engage with yourself. You said you're
not here to what? We're not here to
engage with yourselves. You're scared.
You guys are scared to give da. You guys
are scared to talk about your religion
because you guys don't have answers.
You guys see how pathetic Islam is.
Islam is this pathetic. What does the
Bible say or what does the Quran say? I
can't have I can't have the pepper. What
does the Bible say about Muhammad? I'm
listening. Go ahead. What does the
corrupt scripture say about Muhammad?
Right.
Is God
[Music]
somebody told me to come to
I know you asked me why. You asked me
why. Somebody came and told me Somebody
came and told me to come and talk to
somebody knowledgeable. You know what?
Do you feel Does the cameras make you
brave? No. Put them down there. No, I
think that they can't the truth. I'm
asking you a question. Does the camera
Does it make you feel brave? Does it
scare you? Does the camera scare you?
Yeah. Does it scare you? Muslim. Okay.
Scared. You think these guys scare me?
No. Are you mad? No, I don't think so.
They don't scare me, mate. We don't want
We don't want to scare you now. We don't
want to scare you. Does the Do the
cameras make you brave? Do they scare
you? The cameras make you brave. No. Do
they scare you? They make you brave. No.
Do they scare you? Put them down there.
Do they scare you? Do you want to talk
to me? Yes. Do they scare you? Do you
want to talk to me? Do the cameras scare
you? Do you want to talk to me? Do they
scare you? I answered your question. No,
I'm asking you a question. You know, you
already you already asked me a question.
Do you want to speak to me? I'll talk to
whoever's knowledgeable. Yeah. Do you
want to speak to me? Whoever's
knowledgeable. All right. Come. Do you
want to speak to me? Yeah. Are you
knowledgeable? Do you want to speak to
me? Are you knowledgeable? I could be. I
might not be. Okay. I I would love to.
Yeah. Do you want to speak to me? I
would love to. But listen, what what's
your evidence? Come speak to me alone.
Okay. Just keep the camera. I'll come
by. Why? Why don't you want to speak on
camera? Oh, here we go. Why do you want
to just speak on camera? You just said
to me you want to speak to me. Why don't
you want to speak on camera?
Why? Why? Why don't you want to talk on
camera?
Brother, I just want to talk to you.
Anybody that's anybody that's
knowledgeable. I I I think that you I
think that you don't want to get caught
on camera. I don't think you want to get
caught on I don't think you want to get
caught on camera. I don't think you want
to get caught on camera. It's okay,
brother. speak. It's okay, brother. Is
there anybody knowledgeable? Is there
anybody knowledgeable?
Is there anybody knowledgeable? You are
afraid to speak. Is there an imam, a
shake, somebody?
Is there Is there an imam, a shake? You
You were confident talking to these
guys, right?
You were You were confident talking to
some of these guys, man. I'm here. I'm
here. You was You was confident talking
to these guys. I'm right here, bro. At
the end of the day, we're just here for
the truth. That's it. You got all these
people that's waiting to hear some good
dawa. Give some daisy.
Huh? What do you mean?
Say that one more time.
Like who? You like who, brother? Come
with your security and your cameras.
We're not entertainers.
But I I didn't say you were, but you
guys claim to have the truth on your
show. What? You guys claim to have the
truth. What What What is it? What is it
about all these people? These guys are
supposed to be the Da gods, the Da
Lions.
They got knowledge. They're up on the
hook. They got the truth. Why can't we
ask them a question? What is wrong with
that? You know what? We got one
question. We got one question. What's
our question, y'all?
That's our question. What's the deal?
Can anybody give us an answer?
No answer.
That's it, guys.
You said you're free for what?
I just saw you talking to this other
brother, right? He was a Was he a
Christian?
What what is it about when we come here
try to get some conversations with
Muslims, they always tell me to go to
somebody knowledgeable. When I go to
somebody knowledgeable, they don't never
want to talk. They don't never want to
talk.
Let's let me go to this side. Maybe the
shakes over here might talk. Have you
guys found it?
Have you guys read the yet? It's pretty
good.
The is pretty good.
Tiny. What about the Torah? Y'all read
the Torah? It's pretty good.
It's pretty good. Nothing.
Come on, guys. You guys are always
talking already, man. What happened?
What? What? Shake. Hey, shake to shake,
man. Shake to shake. Shake to another
shake. Y'all good? Shake to another
shake, man. Any of y'all speak Arabic?
Have you guys heard of Jesus? Y'all
learn of Jesus. All right, let me at
least give y'all the gospel, man. Cuz
y'all never heard the gospel before.
This is the gospel. The gospel is that
you're a sinner, my brother, just like
me. Everybody sitting down with your
heads down on your phones. You guys are,
you know, trying to ignore the
conversation. You're all sinners. And
you guys think that Allah, who doesn't
exist, is going to save you guys. You
guys follow a man who did who did
Exactly. No. No, we don't. No, we don't.
We do not.
There we go. Let him talk. Let him talk.
Let him talk. Let him talk. Let him
talk.
Let him talk.
Let her talk.
a grown woman.
I don't understand the problem.
Are you guys under pressure?
Let's see. Let's go talk to the sister.
She's not afraid to talk. Oh my
goodness. Why are they afraid to talk?
This is crazy.
Is that That's right. Hey, if Islam was
so truthful, they wouldn't mind talking.
They wouldn't mind it.
If Muhammad was a true prophet, they
wouldn't mind telling us about him. But
they don't want to tell us about
Muhammad cuz he's a false prophet.
That's tough. He's a false prophet. You
being a false prophet? Yes. He's in my
position. He's your prophet. Okay. Would
do would you like to tell us why? No,
I'm not the one who's talking to you.
You don't want to talk to me. Why is
that, sister? Because I don't want to
talk to you. That's fine. That's I'm not
going I'm not going to push you. It's
all right. God bless you, sister. Turn
to Jesus. Okay. Repent. Jesus is Lord.
Jesus is Lord. He's your only way to
salvation, sis.
I'm here like just, you know, just
trying to engage with you guys. You guys
set up the tent. We're not here to
engage with. You said you're not here to
what? We're not here to engage with
yourselves. With with me? Why? Why not
with me? Because I don't we don't think
it's beneficial. I don't think it's In
what way people can learn and have an
educated conversation? Because we're
aware of who you are. We I've seen you
lie. You see me lie. What What did I lie
about? Uh last time when you came to uh
and you had a conversation with Siraj,
you misqued a verse from the Quran
intention. What did I misquote? I tell
you if if I did, I'll repeat. And then
Sur from his memory, he corrected you.
Wait, what? What? Wait, what did I
misquote? Uh you can go back to the
video. I I I was in the video. I know.
Go back to the video and you see you
said go back to the video. I was in the
video. Go back to it and watch it.
That's what I mean. I But what if you
said that I misqued? The only thing I
said is that it says to first to judge
by the gospel. Let me finish. Okay. You
misqued it. But you if you're saying I
misqued. I'm sorry. If you're if you're
saying I misqued, you got to tell me
what I misqued. I don't have to tell
you. But so you could just throw a claim
out there, an accusation, and just
That's fine. That's That's not fine.
That's not That's not integrity. That's
fine. I'm telling you why we're not
going to engage with you. Because it it
sounds like you don't want to be
challenged on your belief. You would
rather talk to the Christian who doesn't
really know their faith. And but when
someone comes, I know that's your
position. I know that's your
understanding. My understanding is these
brothers, they're happy to talk to you
Christians, but when knowledgeable
Christians come, we don't want to
engage. You can You're showing it right
now. This is exactly what's happening.
We came up We can't You hold on. Hold on
a second. I I cuz I just heard you out.
But you're asking me to explain myself.
Yeah, but you but you but you did. But
we're having a conversation. We're
having a conversation. You do. This is
what you do. Yeah. In a in a
conversation, it takes two to talk. I
listen to you. You listen to me, man.
But you're manipulating. You manipulate
conversation. How? Tell me how. See,
when you give when you give an acc when
you give an accusation, you misquote.
You lie. You uh manipulate conversation.
Tell me what I did exactly. I'm telling
you, you misqued a verse. So what verse
did I misquote?
Chapter 5. And then what verse the
video? Listen, listen. The video is
there online. So, how about this? How
about can you can you just at least say,
you know what, maybe you know you you
miss you're misspeaking because you
don't know the verse I'm quoting. Maybe
hold that accusation for now. Come on. I
I believe like you believe in God. I
believe in the day of judgment.
Question. When I say you misqued the
verse, I'm saying you mistransated it.
You misqued it. I only read from the
book. No way. No, you don't live in your
memory. know and s corrected you. What
did he correct me on? Second reason. So,
you don't have anything. You don't have
nothing that I got corrected on. I quot
I quoted it verbatim. If you're going to
say that I'm if you're going to say that
I misqued it, you have to give me how.
Yes, you do. Okay. So, I could so I
could just throw an accusation at you
and and just be like, "Calas, Coloss, my
bad." That's fine. Do what you want
because the thing is, as I said, I'm not
here. I don't see a position to engage
with you and I'm telling you the reason.
I'm not going to use but these aren't
valid reasons. These aren't valid
reasons. Let me tell you, let me give
you a good example. There's something
that you do which is quite clever. What
you do, you put forth a challenge. So
for example, I'm going to do it as well,
but I don't agree with example. You say
this is an example. You would say prove
to me that Jesus
and I will give you this amount of
money. You don't like this.
Now it seems like an open discussion but
what you've done is quite uh it's
manipulative. What you've done is you
have asked the Muslims to prove to you
their belief and you've made yourself
the judge and the juror. So I don't
think that's a good way to engage with
people. If if a Christian comes like for
example
if a Christian comes and the Christian
says I don't believe in Islam. Yeah. I
don't believe in the Quran. I believe
for example that the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was immoral
for this reason and this reason me I'm
open to have that discussion but when
there's uh there's methods which are
used are manipulative like you
misrepresent Islam and then the then the
whole conversation is that the Muslim
has to emphasize no we Muslims don't
believe that and I say I say it's
disingenuous it's honest okay may I
respond to that really quick you said no
cuz I'm not engaging with Okay. Well, so
you just want you just want to you just
want to talk. So I'm going to actually
respond to you. So guys, what he said
was is that he has a problem with me
challenging Muslims on what they
believe. He said he said when you
challenge Muslims to prove what they
believe, it's a problem. And he actually
doesn't like when other Muslims do it
either, right? He said it's
manipulative. And he said that I become
a judge and jury when I ask them to
prove what they say. So excuse me,
ladies and gentlemen, for saying, "Hey,
I I I know. I know. Forgive me ladies
and gentlemen for saying where do you
get that from? I'm sorry for saying can
you prove that? I'm sorry for saying
where does your Quran say that? My bad
Yousef for challenging you guys on your
belief. So if if you guys are going
around saying Jesus is a Muslim, I have
a right as a Christian to ask you where
do you get that from? Right. Yes. If
you're going to say that Jesus is a
Muslim, you're making a claim. And so if
I ask you how do you demonstrate the
claim, that's upon you to prove it. No,
no, no. Yes. Thank you. So, I'm right.
We have our claim. We have our evidence.
What? What? That's Is it wrong for me to
ask for the evidence? Let me finish. Let
me finish.
He's saying that they make claims and
they have evidence for it. So then I
asked what evidence and he says, "No,
no, no, no.
Listen, listen. I don't You don't need
to speak to me. I just want people to
hear you. That's all me. I never
approach you. You don't approach us. I'm
explaining to you why I don't think it's
beneficial to engage with you. This is
not an invitation or an engagement. I'm
just giving you the reason. If you don't
want to know my reasons, you can leave.
I mean, this is the public place. You
can stay where you want. You can go
where you want. It's okay. I understand.
I know. I I I understand how this is. I
And I appreciate you even voicing, you
know, your opinion. Obviously, I
disagree. My Here's here's my thing,
Yousef, and I and I'll let you go in
peace, brother. My thing is this. When
you have a tent or a table saying, "Ask
us about Islam or Jesus is a Muslim or
the prophets were Muslims and stuff like
that followed Islam." Wait, let me let
me finish. I listen to you patiently. I
I I listen to you patiently. I didn't
invite you. You please. I I I let you I
let you speak, Yousef. So, notice how
notice who's being manipulative right
now. Who's manipulating the conversation
right now?
said, "I'm not going." Yousef, who'ssef,
who's the one who's manipulated
conversation? I didn't agree to have I
know, but but you It's okay, brother.
It's all right. It's all right. Yeah,
but you just said you agreed that you'll
let me finish, right? No. No. So, I'm
going to I'm going to make my point. So,
when you have a tent Okay, I'll make it
to everyone that they can hear. When
Muslims put up a tent that says, "Ask us
about Islam," I'm going to ask y'all
about Islam.
And so when I ask you about Islam, don't
fear.
Don't be afraid. When I ask y'all about
his love, don't say, "Oh, Avery, you're
manipulative. Oh, Avery, you're being
disingenuous." It's okay. He wants to
talk.
If you want to talk, that's fine. So,
how many black people?
How many black people left? How many
black people left Islam? So, here's the
point. The point is, if you're going to
say that I'm manipulative, if you're
going to say that I've made mistakes,
you have to give examples. That's all
I'm saying. You got to give examples.
You see, if you say I'm manipulative,
tell me exactly what I did.
I listen to you patiently. I didn't
finish. You literally said you said you
didn't finish. You got me. So,
it's it's a you're saying that I'm
disingenuous while being disingenuous.
Yeah.
I haven't come to a conversation with
you. I told you from the beginning.
Yeah. Yeah. What do they have? What?
Yeah. What do they have in common?
Because
you guys I'm I'm just a little I'm a
little confused. yesterday. So
from yesterday
why why don't you want to have a conver
you put up you it looks like you guys
want to have a conversation free Quran
English translation say that again
respected
what's an answer that they've given that
was pretty good though the same
misconception yeah what did they clear
You're asking a question of meaning.
Yeah. What? But I understand what what
what did they clear up? I I believe
that. What did they clear up? What did
they clear up? If you said that they've
cleared up a misconception, you said
that they've answered questions. My
question is what did they do? What did
they answer? What? And I'm asking what
did they answer? What did they answer? I
know you don't because you guys set up
and you guys are a bunch of cowards.
You're a bunch of cowards.
You're scared. You guys are scared to
give dawa. You guys are scared to talk
about your religion because you guys
don't have answers.
You guys see how pathetic Islam is?
Islam is this pathetic. What does the
Bible say or what does the Quran say? I
I can't have I can't have the pepper
now. What does the Bible say about? I'm
listening. Go ahead. What does the
corrupt scripture say about Muhammad?
Right.
How do you know my heart? See, I've
watched your videos. Yeah. So what what
gives you the inclination that I'm not
sincere? I just said I watched your
videos. Yeah. What gave you the
inclination that I'm not? You don't need
to explain. Well, you do. If you give an
if you give an accusation, you got to
back it up.
All right. I'm listen
to you about your religion.
Why don't
because you're lost. Because you're lost
and because you have Look, you're out
here giving dawa, right? You're giving
information about Islam. Let let me
finish. Yeah, remember you asked me you
asked me a question. Let me tell you
why. Okay. When you put up a a table,
when you're saying you're giving uh
information about Islam, not just Islam
though, but you bring in Muhammad. Hold
on. Excuse me. You bring in Moses. You
bring in Jesus. You listening, bro. You
bring you bring in Moses. You bring in
Jesus. These are my prophets. Jesus is
my Lord. And you bring in false
information about these people. So, when
you do this, you open yourself up for
someone like me to to come approach you.
That's what I'm saying. Yeah. So, so I
would say then you should put your thing
away. You should tuck it up, pack it up.
And I think that you guys should just,
you know, maybe just leave Islam. Leave
Islam when you guys, you know, until you
guys grow some. Until you guys grow
some.
You were never a Christian. There was no
way. You were never a Christian.
Yeah. You were never a Christian. I bet
you if I asked you basic questions, you
wouldn't be able to answer nothing.
Neither about Christianity or Islam.
That's why you don't want to talk to me.
Yeah, that's fine. No problem. Why is he
butting in? You got you got you you got
roasted last night. It's all about my
soul. My soul is precious to me. I want
to make it when I die. Of course, it's
appointed for a man to die once and then
judgment. And I said to him, he says
it's all about camera. I said now people
around wants to know the truth. We're
going to off the camera for 10 minutes.
You give him a point. He asks you a
question. We ask you unless you actually
tell us the rating. Oh. So, so you want
me to turn my camera off for him? No.
You think that he's going to give give
an honest conversation? No, because he
wants He said that without a camera is
that it's for show. I say it's not for
sure. It's for the truth. For the truth
people to know, they know that it's an
excuse for that. Hang on. Hang on. You
know one thing we do in life. Yeah.
Yeah. You want to prove somebody wrong,
right? Me. No. Hang on. What he's saying
now that he wants to speak to you
without a camera. Let's see who is
confident about the God he's worshiping.
You want to do that? Say that again. We
want to see who is actually confident,
who knows what he's talking. Yeah. If
he's confident, he'll come talk on
camera. He's not going to be scared and
talk on off camera. Like this how you
know my brother. My brother with a
camera and an audience. You have a
golden opportunity for thousands to know
what the truth is to show that whatever
opposition you have doesn't stand.
However, they want to turn the cameras
off. They don't want people to see our
conversation. Why? Why do they want to
hide the conversation? You get what I'm
saying? I understand what you say. Do
something wrong now. That's why I say
what we do because a lot of people are
still recording.
Yeah, we we it's already exposed. The
fact that they don't want to talk
exposes Islam already. Whether they talk
to me, if they talk to me, it's a bad
play. If they don't talk to me, it's a
bad play. You know, they say nothing
Islam is not
converting to Islam than leaving Islam.
Why? Why do you think that can work?
Why? was the truth. But what makes it
the truth? What makes it the truth?
People are sincere. When they go to
prison, they commit a crime. They they
they feel remorse.
Islam is there. They open the Quran.
They see there's only one Quran. They
they've become Muslim. So what would you
say about like a lot of people who are
in the prisons as well who are
converting to Christianity. They say
that they found Jesus in in prison. How
would you would you say that
Christianity is the truth because of
that? I would say that Islam is more
growing in prison and not only in
America in the UK is the fastest growing
doesn't mean that Christianity is not
growing maybe
there are people becoming Christians but
more people are becoming Muslims I don't
think so true so you have a lot of
people that's saying um I'm talking
about imams and shakes they talk about
the the the avalanche of apostasy
because Islam is actually decreasing
really amongst the young like college
people young college kids it's not
decreasing Man, you got Okay, let me You
got a little duck.
You got You got You got You got Listen,
I'm listening. Okay, listen. Who? No.
Take this away from the table. Want to
Yeah.
Is there a problem? What kind of God is
it? It is. So, do you think that is a
problem that God
created the trees? The father, the son
of this,
the three persons are God. Moon, the
father, son, holy spirit. Father, son,
holy spirit. Father, son, holy spirit.
The father said he created everything by
do you think do do you think it's a
problem? Do you think it's a problem
that the father son and holy spirit help
each other? Yeah. But I thought the
father is independent doesn't need help.
Okay. So when Allah says if you help if
if you help me I'll help you.
Wait no no we're talking about both.
We're talking about the concept of God.
No I want the right.
So why does Allah need our help? Oh, in
the Quran. Why does Allah need our help?
The Quran. Wait, why? I don't want to
listen to you. I don't want to listen to
you. I don't want to listen to you.
It's God. It's God. It's God. Don't you
It's God. Touch you.